welcome to bananamores i'm so excited to
watch this next performer light up
the bananamore stage get ready for
comedy greatness
wow mitzi bananamore oh no i just had a
flashback to banana flavored fruit wines
but anyway mitzi hello you
thank you for inviting me to join your
virtual coalition of comedy makers
now as you know i am no comedian or
grand farcier i'm but a humble thespian
but i never turned down an opportunity
to entertain
so in lieu of serenading you with
witticisms i thought i would just tell
her
well a brief story now many of you at
home may not know this but mitzi and i
we go way back yes back when dinosaurs
used to roam the earth
eons ago when we were but we baby
as wide-eyed with grand aspirations of
ticking on the beg
upper and during those days we supported
ourselves as bar maidens in a
well a rather seedy drinking den called
the mug smuggler
was an unnecessarily sticky and dark
establishment
with a proprietor who was a proper
snolly guster
yes he was a hairy hum gruffin who was
simply halitosis personified
and the frequenters were not much more
decorous than him i must say
oh i wouldn't have lasted six minutes in
that place if it wasn't for my
dear burn buddy extraordinaire mitzi who
attended that bar with the grit
and determination of a civil war field
nurse now she was never one to suffer an
income poop and
well she became a mentor of sorts to me
and not just that she showed me how to
make a mai tai without bruising the ram
or how to handle a particularly
difficult
patron shall we say no she taught me how
to stand
just a bit taller and to will never
apologize for being myself
and recently i've been thinking a lot
about that because during the most
trying of times you need those people
in your life who bolster you and well
they remind you to breathe
right when it feels like life is going
to crackle your spirit
so thank you very much mitzi one never
forget small acts of kindness nor did
they forget how odorifis that terrible
bar owner was
you'd think he had never heard of
antiperspirant
oh just the thoughts of him gives me the
caulibles
i can't even get over how much talent
this person has
kind of unfair give a little to the rest
of us